Somehow, most likely through some nefarious
means, a fateful postcard had been sent to
one of the residents of the murky, mysterious
Aranearum island.
Living on this particular island was already
a strange and scary enough existence, given
the horrors the inhabitants of Aranearum shared
their home with.
But perhaps the only thing just as horrible
as life on that island was being sent a postcard.
Sure, that doesn’t sound all that horrible.
Postcards are usually used to show a corner
of the world far away, and extend well wishes
from friends or relatives on vacations.
But ordinarily, postcards don’t depict a
photo of SCP-096, with the words ‘Wish he
was there’ scrawled on the other side.
From its containment cell at the SCP Foundation,
the Shy Guy instantly sensed that somebody,
somewhere, had seen a picture of its face.
Breaking down into an enraged fit of homicidal
insecurity, SCP-096 immediately broke from
its containment chamber and made a cross-country
beeline, heading straight for Aranearum at
anomalously accelerated speeds.
Little did the creature, or the Foundation,
know, that the Shy Guy was being led straight
into a trap.
And the poor island resident who had received
the chilling postcard?
Well, they were unlucky enough to be the bait.
While the SCP Foundation started frantically
trying to track down where it had gone, the
Shy Guy had already made its way to a wooden
cabin belonging to the unfortunate postcard
recipient.
Emerging from the now-emptied home, once the
owner was no more, SCP-096 would have returned
to his cell just as quickly as he left.
That is, if he wasn’t the only monstrous
creature on the island.
A loud and sudden noise caught the creature’s
attention, the sound of an old steam train
whistle.
It rang out once, from somewhere off in the
distance, but there was so much thick fog
hanging in the air around Aranearum that it
was almost impossible to see anything, especially
with how dark it was.
The second time the whistle sounded, it was
closer.
But there was another sound too and not the
loud chugging of a steam engine that you would
expect.
It was an erratic, heavy thudding, the noise
of lots of somethings drumming against the
ground, causing the earth itself to shudder.
Legs.
They were the steps of multiple huge legs,
crawling across the surface of the island:
heading straight towards SCP-096.
A third, piercing whistle rang out, even closer
still.
This time, the orange glow of a light could
be seen, dulled by the surrounding fog, but
getting brighter and clearer as it came closer.
The light was casting shadows against the
dark fog, long, spindly shapes of spidery
appendages.
Until, before the Shy Guy’s eyes, a creature
of pure nightmares came bursting out of the
fog.
It was a monstrous sight, even to SCP-096.
Its body was the red front engine of an old-fashioned
steam train, hoisted off the ground by four
pairs of enormous black, spindly, spider-like
legs that propelled the beast forwards at
a terrifying speed.
Able to move without the limitations of needing
to follow a railroad track, the monster was
barreling towards SCP-096, with a twisted
smile on its grotesque face.
At the front of the locomotive was its circular
face, with unnaturally white eyes and a mouth
that sported rows of razor-sharp teeth, all
covered in blood.
This hellish abomination, a being that was
part steam engine and part giant spider, was
the Terror of Aranearum himself: the carnivorous
Choo-Choo Charles.
Seeing Charles racing towards them on its
eight spider legs would be enough to make
anyone freeze up and stop in their tracks
out of sheer terror.
And SCP-096 was compelled to do the same.
Except the terrifying train creature’s pale
eyes were looking directly at the Shy Guy
as Charles sized the anomaly up as its next
meal.
He was looking at it, and that meant SCP-096
had to kill him.
The question was, how could it?
How could the skinny, spindly humanoid hope
to even fight something like Choo-Choo Charles?
He was much bigger, even more fearsome…
but as quick as Charles could move on his
spidery legs, he wasn’t faster than SCP-096.
In the blink of an eye, the Shy Guy raced
off shrieking and sobbing in despair, leaving
Charles to continue roaming his island territory
in search of other human inhabitants to terrorize.
SCP-096 had retreated to some nearby woods,
quick enough to move out of Charles’ path
somewhere it could hide, for now.
But the Shy Guy could feel a familiar, painful
feeling, almost pulling him back towards Choo-Choo
Charles, right back into harm’s way.
SCP-096 possessed an inescapable compulsion
to kill anyone who looked at its face, and
that seemed to include horrifying part train,
part spider hybrids.
It was a fact of the Shy Guy’s very existence,
he had to go after whoever looked at him and
make them pay.
In fact, it took all the creature’s own
strength not to instantly rush back over to
Charles to try; SCP-096 knew that, if it did,
then there was little chance it would survive
coming face to train face with the Terror
of Aranearum.
However, it was while watching Choo-Choo Charles
from a safe distance, seeing him crawl across
the landscape on his multiple legs, that SCP-096
noticed something.
It was another light obscured by the fog,
but this one was much higher up.
One could almost mistake it for the moon,
if it wasn’t getting closer, all while accompanied
by the sound of whirring rotors.
While the Shy Guy had been evading Choo-Choo
Charles, the SCP Foundation had been tirelessly
trying to track down its location.
And now, they’d found their runaway anomaly
here on Aranearum island.
As the chopper carrying the Mobile Task Force
drew nearer, the tyrannical train turned and
took notice.
To SCP-096, the Foundation’s arrival could
have meant a way home and away from the spidery
steam engine.
But to Charles, the approaching chopper meant
only one thing: a new source of food.
“Captain!”
one of the MTF troops aboard the chopper called
over his headset.
“What is it?
Do we have eyes on SCP-096?”
the captain replied, before realizing what
he’d said.
“Well, not ‘eyes-on’ because then it
would’ve jumped up onto the chopper and
killed us all.
I mean, is there any sign of SCP-096 on the
island?”
“Negative, sir, although you should probably
see this!”
the soldier replied.
Begrudgingly, the captain unbuckled himself
from his seat and snatched the Foundation
operative’s binoculars, using them to look
down at Aranearum below.
It didn’t take him long to spot the massive,
multi-legged monstrosity that was Choo-Choo
Charles, who had fallen still, waiting for
the chopper to descend low enough for him
to reach.
“Good gravy, what on Earth is that thing?!”
the captain exclaimed, before taking another
look through the binoculars.
“Is that… wait, what is an instance of
SCP-2086 doing out here?”
SCP-2086 was an infamous anomalous species
that the Foundation had encountered before.
Much like Charles, they were arthropod-like
creatures with multiple long legs that protruded
from a body resembling a man-made mode of
transport.
However, SCP-2086’s usually took on the
appearance of buses while in vehicle form.
“Sir, I don’t think it’s an SCP-2086,”
the lookout replied.
“To me, it looks much more like an instance
of SCP-3023.”
“Impossible, all the way out here?”
the captain retorted.
“We’re nowhere near the region where that
anomaly occurs.”
“It could have scurried its way from Germany
and taken nest here, sir,” the trooper responded.
Yet another anomaly that Choo-Choo Charles
bore a striking resemblance to, SCP-3023 was
a rare phenomenon that was known to occur
at random, but was limited to a specific area
of Central Germany.
The effect of this phenomenon caused ordinary,
everyday inanimate objects, of any shape or
size, to suddenly turn into aggressive spiders,
sporting eight legs that grew from whatever
was affected by SCP-3023.
Perhaps Choo-Choo Charles was indeed an instance
of SCP-3023, or some distant evolutionary
offshoot of SCP-2086.
It was hard to say for sure.
The only thing for sure was that Charles was
a man-eating beast, more so than an insidious
villain.
And being so highly territorial, he considered
the entire island of Aranearum to be his natural
habitat; and his hunting ground.
Anything that arrived in his vicinity was
prey to the terrifying train, and his ravenous
craving for human flesh meant he was ready
to attack the descending SCP Foundation chopper.
“Alright, let’s go, go, go!”
the MTF captain called to his troops, signaling
them to start rappelling out of the helicopter
and down to the island.
“Keep your SCRAMBLE goggles on max, we still
need to recapture SCP-096, but first priority
is taking down this big, ugly beast!”
Wearing goggles specially designed to distort
the Shy Guy from their view, the team began
abseiling out of the aircraft.
But Choo-Choo Charles was already waiting
for them.
Rearing back on its four back legs, the nightmarish
train-spider swiped at the descending MTF
operatives.
What first seemed like an instinctive, uncoordinated
assault quickly became precise and relentless
strikes as Charles’ sliced through some
of the cables the MTF troops were using to
rappel down.
Their lifeline cut, the unlucky Foundation
operatives plummeted from mid-air, right down
towards where the Terror of Aranearum was
waiting for them to fall.
A few of the MTFs made it to the ground alive,
and immediately began retaliating against
Choo-Choo Charles.
The gunfire from their weapons flickered all
around the carnivorous creature, but their
bullets could barely chip the red paintwork
on his steam train body.
Dashing towards his helpless human prey on
his many legs, Charles began to feast.
Then suddenly, something started pulling at
one of his huge spider legs, pulling Charles
back moments before he had a chance to claim
his latest victim, the captain of the Foundation’s
MTF.
It was SCP-096, having zipped out of hiding
and shrieking wildly as it used all of its
strength to wrench at one of Choo-Choo Charles’
multiple limbs.
Angered that it couldn’t reach the MTF Captain,
the part spider, part train hybrid stomped
the leg that was being pulled, in a successful
attempt to free itself from the Shy Guy’s
grip.
But in the same instant, SCP-096 used its
anomalous speed to reappear in front of the
already angered locomotive monster.
With his railroad rage about to reach its
breaking point, Charles entered into a relentless
rampage, making quick work of the leftover
MTF troops before setting his sights squarely
on SCP-096.
But doing that was his biggest mistake.
Now Choo-Choo Charles had seen the Shy Guy
twice.
And to the insecure anomaly, that meant Charles
had to go.
Traveling faster than even the multi-legged
monstrosity could perceive, SCP-096 began
racing towards Choo-Choo-Charles’ many legs.
The Shy Guy had realized that it didn’t
stand a chance of dealing with the Terror
of Aranearum the same way it handled all the
others that saw its face.
So, instead, it had settled on a new approach,
specially tailored to take down the spider-legged
steam engine.
One by one, SCP-096 started knocking Charles’
many legs out from underneath him, effectively
tripping him up over and over again.
The Shy Guy moved so quick that the cumbersome
Charles could barely react in time, having
one leg after the other knocked out from beneath
him, causing him to tumble to the ground.
Normally, Choo-Choo Charles was smart enough
to retreat if he encountered something that
could fight back.
If he was injured badly enough, the spider-like
creature would scuttle out of harm’s way
in order to heal his wounds.
But the rage at being constantly tripped up
by SCP-096 was distracting Charles from the
Shy Guy’s true ploy.
With every leg it knocked out from underneath
the spidery steam train, SCP-096 had been
gradually directing Charles towards a nearby
gorge.
With a terrifying burst of anomalous speed,
the Shy Guy caused Choo-Choo Charles to topple
over sideways, rolling over himself until
he landed upside down in the bottom of the
rocky gorge.
The multi-legged locomotive monster’s spindly
legs flailed desperately as he tried to reposition
himself, but with no luck.
SCP-096 had managed what first seemed to be
impossible, and beaten the Terror of Aranearum,
Choo-Choo Charles.
Or for now, at least…
Now go and check out “SCP-096 VS SCP-343”
and “SCP-096 VS SCP-106” for more!